ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA CALL THIS
, UH, COMMITTEE ON SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY TOGETHER
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SENATOR MENDAR FOR YOUR
PRESENCE. UH, LET'S ALL LET'S
CALL OUR FRIEND UM MONIQUE LIMÓN
UP TO THE DÍAS TO PRESENT S¼ B
1036. ITEM ONE IN YOUR. GOOD
MORNING, UH, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY, I PRESENT TO YOU S¼ B
1036, WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
CLEAR PROTECTIONS FOR PURCHASERS
OF CARBON OFFSETS. TAKING
INSPIRATION IN PART FROM SB
THREE. 140 THREE AUTHORED BY THE
CHAIR LAST SESSION. THIS SPILLS
ON CALIFORNIA'S LONG STANDING
FALSE ADVERTISING LAW BY
SPECIFYING OUR EXPECTATIONS FOR
BUSINESS ACTIVITIES RELATING TO
VOLUNTARY CARBON OFFSETS.
VOLUNTARY CARBON OFFSETS ARE
TRADABLE FINANCIAL INSTRUMENT
THAT CLAIM TO REPRESENT A
REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
GASSES IN THE ATMOSPHERE. THE
LEGITIMACY OF CARBON OFFSETS IS
DETERMINED BY ANSWERS TO KEY
QUESTIONS LIKE WHETHER THEY
CLAIM CARBON BENEFITS ARE REAL
AND QUANTIFIABLE, AND WHETHER
THEY CLAIM CARBON BENEFITS WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE OFFSET
ARRANGEMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS AND INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTERS HAVE UNCOVERED MANY
EXAMPLES OF OFFSETS OF OFFSET
PROJECTS THAT SIMPLY FAIL TO
DELIVER THE CLAIMED CARBON
BENEFITS. SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
INCLUDE SOME PROJECTS, UM,
RELATED TO FOREST LANDS THAT
HAVE THAT HAVE THAT WERE NEVER
AT RISK OF LOGGING,
REFORESTATION PROJECTS, UH, WITH
PHYSICAL IMPOSSIBLE ASSUMPTIONS
OF TREE GROWTH AND RELATED
CARBON SEQUESTRATION AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS IN
JURISDICTIONS WHERE IT IS
CHEAPER TO BUILD RENEWABLE
GENERATION THE TRADITIONAL
FOSSIL FUEL PLANTS. THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON VOLUNTARY OFFSETS, AS
IMPLIED BY THEIR NAME. THESE
OFFS OFFSETS ARE PURCHASED ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS. AND ARE NOT
RELATED TO LEGAL REQUIREMENTS OR
REGULATORY PROGRAMS LIKE
COMPLIANCE OFFSETS IN OUR CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. SO WHAT IS
THE HARM IF VOLUNTARY OFFSETS DO
NOT LIVE TO ITS CLAIM VALUE?
THERE ARE TWO GENERAL CHALLENGES
WITH ALLOWING LOW QUALITY
OFFSETS TO REMAIN UNADDRESSED
FIRST. CONSUMERS ARE HARMED WHEN
THEY DO NOT GET WHAT THEY PAY
FOR. A CONSUMER WHO PURCHASES AN
OFFSET TO MITIGATE THE EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INTERNATIONAL
FLIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE, EXPECTS
THAT THAT OFFSET TO ACTUALLY
DELIVER SOME ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT. AND EVEN MORE COMMONLY,
BUSINESSES MAKE GREEN CLAIMS
SUCH AS THEIR PRODUCTS BEING NET
ZERO OR CARBON NEUTRAL. IF THAT
BUSINESS RELIES ON LOW QUALITY
OFFSETS TO SUPPORT SUCH CLAIMS,
THE CONSUMER MAY BE MISLED TO
BELIEVE THAT THEIR CONSUMPTION
HAS NÓ NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. IN BOTH CASES,
CONSUMERS ARE ENTICED TO BUY
SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE BUY BASED ON
MISLEADING CLAIMS, A CLASSIC
VIOLATION OF OUR CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS. THE SECOND
GENERAL CHALLENGE WITH THE LOW
QUALITY OFFSETS. IS THERE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. CORPORATIONS WHO
PURCHASE LOW QUALITY OFFSETS MAY
IGNORE CHANGES IN THEIR OWN
OPERATIONS THAT COULD REDUCE
THEIR EMISSIONS DIRECTLY.
SIMILARLY LOW QUALITY OFFSETS
PROJECTS, UM, SIPHON FINANCING
AWAY FROM INVESTMENTS IN HIGH
QUALITY CARBON REMOVAL PROJECTS.
WITH SUCH A STEEP HILL TO CLIMB
TO ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE
CHALLENGES. WE SIMPLY CANNOT
ALLOW FOR LOW QUALITY OFFSETS TO
GET IN THE WAY OF OUR GOALS. SB
1036 PROVIDES LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS FOR
VOLUNTARY CARBON OFFSETS A
POLICY THAT IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND OUR
CLIMATE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
TODAY WE HAVE MELISSA ROMERO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS AND PAUL
MASON OF PACIFIC FOREST TRUST.
YOU. YOU CAN YOU CAN COME OH, DO
I COME UP THERE? EITHER WAY?
YEAH, YEAH. YEAH. HUH? OK GOOD
MORNING. MELISSA ROMERO,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS,
UH, HERE IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1036
BY SENATOR LIMÓN. THIS BILL IS A
CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THE INTEGRITY OF VOLUNTARY
CARBON OFFSETS MARKET AND
HOLDING CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITMENTS. THE
PHILOSOPHY BEHIND OFFSETS IS TO
INCENTIVIZE GHG REDUCTIONS THAT
ARE COST-EFFECTIVE OR MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. HOWEVER THE CURRENT
LACK OF REGULATION IN THESE
MARKETS HAS LED TO SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES, PARTICULARLY WITH LOW
QUALITY OFFSETS. THIS BILL AIMS
TO ADDRESS THE RAMPANT PROBLEM
OF JUNK OFFSETS, WHICH OFTEN
FAIL TO DELIVER ON THE PROMISED
CARBON REDUCTIONS. AND THERE ARE
EXAMPLES OF OFFSETS, BACKED BY
PROJECTS WITH REALLY DUBIOUS
CLAIMS OF CARBON BENEFITS FROM
FALSELY LABELED FOREST LANDS
THAT WERE CLEAR CUT TO RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS ALREADY IN
MOTION. THOSE OFFSETS DO NOT
LIVE UP TO THEIR PREMISES. NOT
ONLY DO THEY DECEIVE CONSUMERS,
BUT THEY UNDERMINE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND DIVERT FUNDING FROM
EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE PROJECTS.
RELYING ON OFFSETS THAT LATER
PROVED TO BE INEFFECTIVE, ONLY
PERPETUATES RISING EMISSIONS. SB
1036 IS A MEASURE THAT WILL
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT, ENSURING THAT
OFFSETS TRULY DELIVER THE
PROMISED CLIMATE BENEFITS.
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY IS
ESSENTIAL IN THIS CONTEXT,
COMPANIES THAT PURCHASE OFFSETS
TO MEET THEIR NET ZERO GOALS
MUST BE ABLE TO RELY ON THE
ACCURACY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE OFFSETS. OTHERWISE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITMENTS BECOME
MEANINGLESS, UH RATHER THAN
GENUINE EFFORTS TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE, AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
S¼ B 1036. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
CHAIR ALLEN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, PAUL MASON OF THE
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST. PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST HAS A LONG HISTORY
IN THIS SPACE OF FORESTS.
CLIMATE OFFSETS ABOUT 20 YEARS
AGO, PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
SPONSORED THE BILL WITH SENATOR
CHER THAT CREATED THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION RESERVE. THEY
THEN WENT ON TO DEVELOP THE
FIRST OF THE VOLUNTARY FOREST
CARBON OFFSETS THAT WAS
EVENTUALLY PORTED OVER INTO THE
COMPLIANCE OFFSETS THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD USES AND MY BOSS
IS CURRENTLY CHAIRING THE EXPERT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE A B
1757. PROCESS THAT'S TRYING TO
SET SOME TARGETS AND NATURAL
WORKING LANDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE LANDS ARE REALLY LEVERAGED
TO MEET OUR STATE CLIMATE
TARGETS, SO WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ROLE OF LANDS
AND, UH, NATURAL WORLD TO TRY
AND MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF OFFSETS.
THE REALLY CRITICAL PIECE HERE,
THOUGH, IS QUALITY. YOU KNOW,
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE WHEN WE
HAVE OFFSETS THAT DON'T ACTUALLY
DELIVER THE LONG TERM BENEFITS
TO ACTUALLY OFFSET THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OVER
THEIR ENTIRE LIFETIME THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. SO WE HAVE THE
CLIMATE HARM. BUT IF WE HAVE
OFFSETS OUT THERE THAT ARE NOT
ACTUALLY FULFILLING THE WHAT?
WHAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY SOLD AS
THAT UNDERMINES THE ENTIRE
CONCEPT OF USING OFFSETS IN THE
REGULATORY SPACE, OR, YOU KNOW,
USING NATURAL LAND. AS WAYS TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE ESSENTIAL
FOR WINNING OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
SO WE THINK IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT THE VOLUNTARY
MARKET IS OF QUALITY. I MEAN,
THAT'S WHY THE REGULATORY OF THE
COMPLIANCE MARKET. THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD RUNS HAS A VERY
HIGH VALUE TO THOSE OFFSETS
BECAUSE THEY ARE OF QUALITY AND
AS OPPOSED TO THE VERY LOW VALUE
SOME OF THE VOLUNTARY OFFSETS
BECAUSE THE QUALITY IS DUBIOUS
QUALITY ALSO BRINGS FINANCIAL
REWARD. THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE BILL,
AND I THINK THERE ARE PLACES
WHERE IT CAN BE CLARIFIED AND
IMPROVED GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. BUT THE UNDERLYING GOAL
OF THE BILL IS BOTH MERITORIOUS
AND NECESSARY, AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. UM SO NEXT,
WE'LL HEAR FOLKS WHO WANNA ADD
ON AND SUPPORT. AT THE MIC. HØI
I'M MICHELLE. PASSER WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. WE'RE IN A
SUPPORT IF A MAN IN POSITION SO
I JUST I HOPE I CAN STILL TO SAY
A FEW WORDS IF YOU DON'T MIND.
UM I'VE WORKED ON CARBON
ACCOUNTING AND THE PROTOCOL
SINCE, UH, THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION REGISTRY BACK IN
2000 WORKING ON THE FOREST
PROTOCOLS. THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY SUPPORTS THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL TO SUPPORT THE, UM
THE TRANSPARENCY, INTEGRITY OF
VOLUNTARY OFFSETS WE DO LAST
YEAR, A 1305 WAS ADOPTED TO YOU.
OK, I JUST WE THINK THERE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO, UH,
FOCUS ON REGISTRIES FOR THIS
BILL, SO WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU TO REALLY FOCUS ON
REGISTRIES WHO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES AND TRANSPARENCY. SO IT'S
NOT DUPLICATIVE OF A B 1305,
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR. HAPPY TO HELP AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SAVANNAH JORGENSEN WITH THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
UH, YES. OK. YEAH. HEY. GOOD
MORNING. UH, SCOTT SADLER ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. UH, WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS, UH, COMMITMENT TO
THIS AND WE SUPPORT GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
WE PROVIDED AMENDMENTS THAT WE
THINK, UH, ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO FROM LAST TIME
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S HEAR FROM
A COUPLE OF OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES EACH. I,
I, YOU CAN COME UP HERE. THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO. YEAH. YEAH. AYE,
SIR. UM WE HAVE LET ME JUST LET
ME GET A QUORUM ESTABLISHMENT.
HAVE A SEAT, AND WE'LL WE'LL
WE'LL WE'LL HEAR FROM YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. UH, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. UM
SENATORS, ALLEN ALLEN HERE,
DOLLY! GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE,
HURTADO HURTADO HERE, MENJIVAR
MENJIVAR HERE WHEN HERE, SKINNER
OK, ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU MAY PROCEED. UM THANK YOU.
CHAIR BRADY VAN ENGLAND,
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
UM, HERE ON BEHALF OF A BROADER
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF COMPONENTS THAT WE
FIND, UM TROUBLING AND
PROBLEMATIC. UM, AND OUR OUR
OPPOSITION. EXCUSE ME. IS BASED
ON A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS HERE.
FIRST THE CHILLING NATURE OF
LAWSUITS THAT COULD STEM FROM
THIS MEASURE MEAN THAT CARBON
CREDIT STANDARDS, REGISTRATION
BODIES, PROJECT DEVELOPERS AND
OTHER COMPONENTS TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING CARBON MARKET ECOSYSTEM
COULD BE SUBJECT TO LITIGATION.
INCREASED LIABILITY ISN'T GOING
TO INCREASE THE DEGREES OF
ASSURANCE THAT WOULD BRING
FORWARD MORE QUALITY PROJECTS
BUT RATHER DISCOURAGE ASSURANCES
TO DUE TO THE FACT THE MEASURE
TAKES AIM AT THOSE VERY SAME
PEOPLE THAT ARE OFFERING THOSE
ASSURANCES ON OFFSETS. ALSO IT'S
WORTH QUESTIONING WHETHER THIS
ISSUE YOU KNOW, PUTTING THIS
ISSUE INTO THE COURTS SYSTEM IS
MERITORIOUS OR IF THE BILL EVEN
CONTEMPLATES THE NECESSARY
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO ACTUALLY PUT THIS INTO THE
COURT SYSTEM. RIGHT NOW. I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY COURT SYSTEM THAT
HAS THE TECHNICAL KNOW HOW TO
ACTUALLY DEFINE LIKE WHAT? YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE PROJECT
GUIDELINES WHETHER THEY'RE REAL,
QUANTIFIABLE AND ADDITIONAL, UM
THIS MEANS THEY'RE EITHER GOING
TO HAVE TO STAFF UP WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO AUGMENT
IN SOME FORM OR FASHION AND
AGAIN, JUST POINTING OUT THERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY, YOU
KNOW, AUGMENTATION ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY AFFORD THAT TO HAPPEN.
UM AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STANDARDS. I JUST, YOU KNOW,
BEYOND THAT. JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STANDARDS THAT ACTUALLY DO
EXIST. UM I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR
MADE CLEAR THAT UH UH, YOUR BILL
LAST YEAR S¼ P 340 THREE IS
SOMETHING BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OTHER, UM ME, YOU KNOW
STANDARDS THAT EXIST WITHIN THE
CARBON ACCOUNTING ECOSYSTEM THAT
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE AWARE OF
BEFORE. YOU KNOW, WE MOVE
FORWARD HERE. UM AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS BILL DOESN'T
SEEM TO BORROW FROM ANY OF
THOSE, IN FACT, KIND OF DISPLACE
SOME OF THE DEFINITIONS THAT ARE
USED, UM, FROM DIFFERENT EFFORTS
. UH, FOR EXAMPLE, THE F Tð èC
HAS GREEN GUIDELINES. THOSE WERE
FIRST ESTABLISHED IN 2012.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING UPDATED RIGHT NOW, UM,
BEYOND THAT, THERE IS AN I S¼ Ó
STANDARD FOR, UH, CARBON OFFSETS
. IT'S I S¼ Ó 14 Ó 6 4 DASH
THREE UH, 2019. SO THERE IS
ACTUALLY AN I S¼ Ó STANDARD FOR
YOU KNOW, THE VÆ èC Ó MARKET
ITSELF AND BEYOND THAT, UH, THE
INDUSTRY HAS TAKEN UPON ITSELF
TO WORK, YOU KNOW, WORK THROUGH
THIS, AND IT'S CREATED. IT'S
CALLED THE INTEGRITY. COUNCIL
FOR VOLUNTARY CARBON MARKETS,
THE BCM, WHICH IS DEVELOPED A
SET OF CORE CARBON PRINCIPLES,
AND THOSE ARE BEING PUT FORWARD,
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS SEEMS TO
CIRCUMVENT THAT PROCESS. QUITE
FRANKLY, SO, UM THAT YOU KNOW
THAT MORE SPECIFICALLY, ONE OF
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE IS WITH THE
DEFINITION OF ATMOSPHERIC LIFE.
TIME OF CO. TWO AND DURABILITY.
SIMPLY PUT. THERE IS NÓ ACCEPTED
DEFINITION OF DURABILITY, AND
SIMILARLY, THE ATMOSPHERIC
LIFETIME OF CO TWO CAN VARY
WIDELY. AND THIS ISN'T JUST ME
SAYING THIS. THIS IS THE IP èC
èC. UM, IT'S PART OF THEIR
REPORT IN 2021 THAT MADE THIS
CLEAR. SO, UM SO IT'S NOT
FEASIBLE TO VERIFY THAT THE
PROJECT ABILITY IS GREATER THAN
OR EQUAL TO THE ATMOSPHERIC AND
THE CO TWO THE ATMOSPHERIC
LIFETIME OF CO TWO COMPONENT IS
GOING TO HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS WHERE PERMANENCE
OF CARBON STORAGE MAY BE CLOSER
TO THE HUNDREDS OF YEARS RATHER
THAN THOUSANDS OF YEARS. THIS
SEEMS TO BE CONTRARY TO THE
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS.
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY DEVELOPED
BY èC  N R A HAS A REQUIREMENT
OF S¼ P 27. NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS CAN PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN CLIMATE MITIGATION. AS
MUCH HAS BEEN SAID BY CAR, PART
OF THEIR SCOPING PLAN AND BY
OTHERS WHO HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS MIGHT
MAKE UP TO 30% OF THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE MITIGATION EFFORTS BY
2050. FOR THESE REASONS, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. OK, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. UM OTHER FOLKS,
YOU WANNA VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION
ON THE MIC? ADD ON DID I GO? ME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. MY NAME
IS LESLIE GERSHEN. I'M THE
FOUNDER AND èC E Ó OF TERRA
GLOBAL. WE ARE A CALIFORNIA
BASED WOMAN FOUNDED WOMAN RUN
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES, UH,
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS CLIMATE
FINANCE TO DEVELOPING COUNTRIES
TO PRODUCE A CLIMATE AND
COMMUNITY BENEFIT. I'M ALSO HERE
AS A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL EMISSIONS TRADING
ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS A GLOBAL
ASSOCIATION OF ALL SECTOR
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT'S PROMOTING
MARKETS. UH, TO REACH OUR GLOBAL
NET ZERO GOALS. AND SO I'D LIKE
TO RESPECTFULLY, UM, OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS. SO
WE'RE WE'RE JUST I'M SO SORRY.
WE'RE WE'RE ASKING FOLKS TO IF
YOU WANNA MAKE SOME VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS, BUT THIS WAS THE
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS. FINE
UH, THE BILL DOES NOT ENSURE
INTEGRITY. WE THERE'S A NUMBER
AS MENTIONED OF OTHER, UH,
ARENAS IN WHICH INTEGRITY IS
ENSURED, AND IN FACT, IT
DISCOURAGES ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS AND THE MEMBERS OF EDA FROM
ACTUALLY TAKING CLIMATE ACTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
AND WE'LL OBVIOUSLY STAY HERE.
WE MAY HAVE IT. BROADER
DISCUSSION. GOOD MORNING, JOANNE
BITTENCOURT ON BEHALF OF SIFMA,
THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION, A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS,
MELANIE CUEVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
ALSO IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SMITH
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF A NEW
CLIMATE LL èC NEW CLIMATE HAS
LONG BEEN INVOLVED IN VOLUNTARY
AND COMPLIANCE MARKETS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. UM WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL FOR REASONS
STATED IN OUR MARCH 12TH LETTER,
AND, UM JUST WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT LOW QUALITY CARBON
CREDITS. WHICH DO EXIST.
HOWEVER. THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF HIGH QUALITY CARBON
CREDITS THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT
AND INCENTIVIZE IN. THIS BILL
DOES NOT ACCOMPLISH THAT. THANK
YOU. MORNING UH, ZACH LEARY ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
DEAN TALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S BRING THE ITEM BACK FOR
DISCUSSION OR QUESTIONS. UM, DO
SENATOR. MAYBE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GIVE SOME RESPONSES TO, UH SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION? SO II? I GUESS I'LL
START WITH SAYING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU KNOW THE
THAT SOME OF THE FOLKS HAVE
BROUGHT TO US WOULD ACTUALLY
UNDERMINE. UM THE YOU KNOW THE
BILL ITSELF. UM AS FAR AS THE
ASPECT OF, UH, THE COURTS, UM
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS BELONGS
IN THE COURTS. THIS IS IN THE
COURTS AT THE MOMENT, UM,
INDEPENDENT OF THIS BILL, YOU
HAVE COMPANIES AT THIS VERY
MOMENT WHO ARE BEING SUED? UM
THROUGH CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS
, UM, AND THE COURTS HAVE YET TO
DISMISS THE CASE. DESPITE THE
INITIAL FILING BEING A PROPOSAL
TO DISMISS THE CASE, I THINK WE,
YOU KNOW, COURTS DEAL WITH
COMPLEX ISSUE ALL THE TIME. SO
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT THE COURTS
CANNOT DEAL WITH AN ISSUE LIKE
THIS. UM, I, I DON'T THINK IS I
THE TRUTH, II. I THINK THAT THE
REALITY IS THAT THAT IS WHY THAT
IT'S IN COURTS AT THIS MOMENT.
UM AND SO, LOOK, I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST QUESTION IS
WHY DID THIS BILL GO FROM
RECEIVING BIPARTISAN BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST YEAR,
TOO NOW HAVING A LOT OF
OPPOSITION, AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S A BIGGER CONVERSATION
HERE TO BE HAD ABOUT THE CONCERN
THAT THEY THAT THE CONCERNS
THERE ARE AROUND. SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S PASSED
RELATED TO GREENWASHING
GREENWASHING. AND SO THIS IS ALL
INTERCONNECTED. UM, THIS IS ONE
VERY PARTICULAR ASPECT.
VOLUNTARY OFFSETS RIGHT. ONE
VERY PARTICULAR AS ASPECT. IT'S
A NARROW ASPECT, AND WE WANT TO
FIND A WAY TO ENSURE THAT WHAT
ENTITIES CLAIM TO DO THEY DO
THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED. UM OR
THE DESIRE OF THIS BILL IS NOT
TO SHUT DOWN THE VOLUNTARY
OFFSET IT IS ACTUALLY TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE BEING
LITIGATED AT THIS MOMENT IN OUR
COURTS IN THE UNITED STATES, UM,
AND TO SAY HERE IS A DEFINITION
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAVE. AND
HERE IS THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
WE MEAN BY THESE HIGH QUALITY
OFFSETS SO THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT. OK? APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER. UM YES, SENATOR HURTADO.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY MOVE THE
BILL WHEN? YEAH, GREAT. WELL. UM
OTHER QUESTIONS. SHOULD WE TAKE
THAT AS YOU CLOSE? ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. I KNOW THAT I KNOW
THE BILL IS GONNA HAVE WIND
ALONG A WINDING ROAD. YOU YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. IT IT IT WAS
IT. IT GOT THROUGH VERY EASILY
LAST YEAR. UM OBVIOUSLY, UM, I,
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK
OUT SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED, UH, BECAUSE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO FROM LAST
YEAR AND SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
REMAIN SO I. I WISH YOU THE BEST
WITH THAT, AND AS YOU WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND ALSO SOME OF
THE TWEENERS WE HEARD FROM THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND OTHERS.
SO, UM WITH THAT. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. SB 1036. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATORS
ALLEN A AND I DALLY. GONZALES.
HER TATO HURT, TATO I MJ WHEN
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S NOW HEAR FROM
OUR NEXT SENATOR ARCHULETA. UH,
WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT S¼ B 1158.
THAT'S ITEM SIX IN YOUR PACKETS
MEMBERS. OH, THANK YOU. WELL,
THANK YOU, UH, MR PRESIDENT, AND
GOOD MORNING TO ALL, UM I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. UH, TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL 1158,
WHICH EXTENDS THE TIME ALL
DISTRICTS HAVE TO DISPERSE KARL
MOYER PROGRAM FUNDS FROM FOUR
YEARS TO SIX YEARS AND INCREASES
THE PORTION OF THE FUNDS
PERMISSIBLE FOR INDIRECT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FROM 6.25%
TO 12 POINT, UH, POINT 5% FOR
LARGER DISTRICTS FOR CLARITY.
THIS PERCENTAGE INCREASE SIMPLY
ALIGNS. THE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
LEVELS FOR LARGER AND SMALLER
DISTRICTS AND DOES NOT ADD COSTS
TO THE PROGRAM. THE KARL MOYER
PROGRAM IS A PROVEN COST
EFFECTIVE CLEAN AIR PROGRAM
MINISTERED BY LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS THAT PROVIDES
INCENTIVES TO PRIVATE BUSINESSES
AND PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
VOLUNTARILY CLEAN UP OLDER,
DIRTIER VEHICLES AND MOBILE OFF
ROAD ENGINES WITH CLEANER THAN
REQUIRED ENGINES, EQUIPMENT AND
EMISSIONS REDUCTION
TECHNOLOGIES. SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN 1998, THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CENTER PROGRAM HAS
ENABLED THE REPLACEMENTS AND
SCRAPPAGE OR REPOWER OF OVER
68,000 ENGINES, RESULTING IN
REDUCTION OF MORE THAN 100 AND
98,000 TONS OF NEUTRO OXIDES AND
REACTIVE ORGANIC GASSES. THE
MORE PROGRAM HELPS TO REDUCE
HARMFUL EMISSIONS IN ORDER TO
REDUCE SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS,
SUCH AS ASTHMA, BRONCHITIS,
DECREASED LUNG GROWTH IN
CHILDREN, CANCER AND PREMATURE
DEATH. THE MOYER PROGRAM
BENEFITS, LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC EMISSIONS.
HOWEVER CURRENT GLOBAL ECONOMIC
TRENDS HAVE AMPLIFIED THE NEED
FOR THE MO PROGRAM TO BE MO
MODERNIZED EX EXTERNAL ECONOMIC
IMPACTS INCLUDING INFLATION AND
SUPPLY CHAINS, INCLUDING
INCLUDES, UH THAT IN AND THAT
THE SHANE AND THESE ISSUES HAVE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AIR DISTRICT
ABILITY TO OPERATE THIS VALUABLE
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE MOYER PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN LATE 1990. SINCE
THEN, THE MORE PROJECTS HAVE
BECOME SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
COMPLICATED AND THE VOLUME OF
PROJECTS HAS RISEN DRAMATICALLY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE FIRST YEAR OF
THE MEAL PROGRAM IN 1998 99,
SOUTH COAST, IMPLEMENTED
APPROXIMATELY $9 MILLION IN
REWARDS. AND AWARDS COMPARED TO
AROUND 100 AND 96 MILLION IN THE
MOST CURRENT FUNDING YEAR. THIS
SHOWS BOTH THE SUCCESS AND THE
PROGRAM AND THE NEED FOR UPDATES
TO ENSURE THAT THE OLD SUCCESSES
WILL CONTINUE. BY EXPANDING,
LIQUIDATED LIQUIDATION TIME AND
INCREASING INDIRECT
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR LARGER
AIR DISKS. WE WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AIR DISTRICTS ARE
ABLE TO CONTINUE SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTING THIS VITAL PROGRAM.
WITH ME TO DAY TO TESTIFY, IF
YOU WOULD LIKE, IS ERIN
KATZENSTEIN, UH, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN ALLEN
AVES, LEGISLATIVE OFFICER FOR
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. THIS BILL
HAS NÓ OPPOSITION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. COME ON,
UP AND TELL US WHAT YOU GOT. YOU
MAY PERCEIVE WHEN READY. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M ERIN
KATZENSTEIN. I'M THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT OFFICE OF
THE SOUTH COAST. IMAGINE
DISTRICT SO WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S¼ PLM 58, AND WE'RE
SERVING AS THE BILL'S SPONSOR.
UH, THE BILL WOULD MOVE TO WILL
MOVE THE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE CARM
OIL PROGRAM TO THE NEXT PHASE
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO IMPLEMENT
MORE ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
AS THESE TECH TECHNOLOGY BECOME
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE. FIRST WE
NEED AN EXTENDED FUNDING
LOCATION TIME DUE TO SEVERAL
REASONS. WE STILL SEE SUPPLY
CHAIN CHALLENGES IN PARTICULAR
WITH TRUCK CHASSIS. RIGHT NOW.
THOSE ARE BEING DELAYED BY
MONTHS. THE WAR IN UKRAINE HAS
RESULTED IN DELAYS FOR AIR
CONDITIONERS FOR BATTERY
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES. AND WE
SEE LABOR SHORTAGES IN
PARTICULAR WITH OUR MARINE
PROJECTS. IN ADDITION, THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT LIKE BATTERY ELECTRIC
AND HYDROGEN TRUCKS REQUIRES
CONSTRUCTION OF SUPPORTING ZERO
EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS DELAYING
LONGER THAN WE EXPECTED. LARGELY
DUE TO PERMITTING SWITCH GEAR.
UM DELIVERIES OR 18 TO 24 MONTHS
DELAYED. AND THEN LASTLY, UH,
MOYER, SUCCESS HAS REALLY MADE
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE
SUBSTANTIAL STAFF RESOURCES AIR
DISTRICTS INVEST IN THE PROGRAM.
SO APPLICATIONS AND PROJECTS
FUNDED, UH, THROUGH MOYER HAVE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS HAVE REALLY, UH,
INCREASED. SO WITH THE RISE OF
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, LARGER
AIR DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR HAVE
BEEN INCURRING INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS THAT EXCEED OUR CURRENT
ALLOTMENTS. AND THE BILL
RECOGNIZES THESE CHALLENGES. SO
TYPICALLY WHEN WE HAVE
APPLICATIONS FROM WIRE TO SOUTH
KO M Dð WE GET THREE TO FOUR
TIMES MORE APPLICATIONS THAN WE
HAVE FUNDING AND WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH EVERY APPLICATION TO
MAKE SURE WE FIND THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE APPLICATION AND
PROJECTS TO THE MOYER PROGRAM.
AND THEN IN ADDITION, THESE
PROJECTS ONCE WE FUND THEM, THEY
CAN LAST UP TO 15 YEARS. WE HAVE
CONTINUED REPORTING AND
MONITORING FOR THESE PROJECTS,
AND THEY OFTEN REQUIRE SEVERAL
MODIFICATIONS OF CONTRACTS. AND
THEN, LASTLY, JUST RISING
INFLATION HAS EXACERBATED THE
GROWING NEED FOR IMPLEMENTATION
RESOURCES FOR THE MOYER PROGRAM.
WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO JUST WRAP
UP THE CON. THAT'S WHAT
SUGGESTING IT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
MEETING. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
THANK YOU. CHAIR ALLEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ALAN ABS WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT, NINE COUNTY REGIONS
SERVING 7.5 MILLION RESIDENTS,
ONE OF THE LARGEST
ADMINISTRATORS OF THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM WE ADMINISTER ABOUT 20%
OF THE ANNUAL FUNDING. UH, IT'S
AS UH, AARON SAID. IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR AND COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE GET APPLICATIONS THAT,
UM, EXCEED THE AVAILABLE, UH,
AMOUNT OF FUNDING, UH, BY ORDERS
OF MAGNITUDE, WHICH REQUIRE A
LOT OF STAFF. TIME TO PRIORITIZE
WHICH PROJECTS WE'RE GONNA FUND,
UM THROUGHOUT THE NINE COUNTY
REGION WHEN CARL MOYER STARTED
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED IN 1998
, THE PROGRAM WAS RELATIVELY
SIMPLE. YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
SURPLUS EMISSION REDUCTIONS, AND
SO WHEN YOU HAVE A UNCONTROLLED
DIESEL ENGINE, IT'S VERY EASY TO
MEET THAT CRITERIA FROM THE FROM
THE PROJECT. UH, LOOK AT IT FOR
FIVE YEARS. UM BUT NOW AS DR
KATZENSTEIN HAS HAS MENTIONED,
UH, WE HAVE INCREASED TECHNOLOGY
REQUIREMENTS A LOT LESS SURPLUS
EMISSIONS. A LOT OF REGULATIONS
THAT, UH, THAT DRIVE WHICH
PROJECTS CAN AND CAN'T BE FUNDED
. IT MAKES IT REALLY CHALLENGING
FOR US TO, YOU KNOW, GO THROUGH
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FUNDING
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE ONES, UM
, GETTING THE APPLICANTS THROUGH
THE PROCESS, WHICH CAN TAKE A
LONG TIME PROJECTS DROP OUT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING. UM IN THE ABSENCE OF
THE ADDITIONAL CARL MOYER
FUNDING THAT WE GET, AND SO IT
MAKES DOING THESE PROJECTS A LOT
MORE COMPLICATED THAN, UH, WHEN
WE INITIALLY STARTED DOING IT
2530 YEARS AGO, SO WITH THAT
BEING SAID, I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT THE BAY AREAS PROGRAM AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YEAH, FOLKS. WANNA ADD
SOME SUPPORT? YES MR CHAIR
MEMBERS, BRENDAN TIG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS FROM ALL 35
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OK I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. BUT IF THERE IS
ANYONE HERE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL OR
OPPOSITION OK, UM, DISCUSSION.
UM NÓ YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS? YOU
WANNA? UH OH, I APPRECIATE I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON ON THIS.
UH AND, UM YOU KNOW, WE FOLLOW
CAR CARL, MO VERY CLOSELY IN
THIS COMMITTEE, OF COURSE, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP. SO,
UM, I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN I HAVE SOME
FRIENDS HERE. YOU'RE ALL FRIENDS
, TOO. BUT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
MOVE THE BILL. SO UM, BUT THANK
YOU, IF YOU IF ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS JUST, UH, MR CHAIR I, I
RESPECT TO ASK YOUR I VOTE. OK,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
UH, THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
APPRECIATE IT. UH SENATOR NEWMAN
CLAIMS TO BE ON HIS WAY. YES OK,
GREAT. I KNOW HE'S CHAIRING
EDUCATION, BUT HE WILL BE
PRESENTING AN S¼ P 1113 AND THEN
ASSUMING HE, UM GETS HERE REALLY
QUICKLY. UH, WE'LL JUST WE'LL
HEAR FROM HIM AND THEN I'LL GO
AHEAD. AND AFTER THAT, I'LL
PRESENT 1136, WHICH IS SENATOR
STERN'S BILL. SENATOR STERN IS
SICK AND BAD IN LOS ANGELES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO? I
CAN'T PRESENT MYSELF NÓ. I'M NOT
ALLOWED. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, HERE'S THE MAN
HIMSELF. THE GREAT CHAMPION. FOR
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING.
AND ESPECIALLY PILOT PROJECTS,
EXTENSIONS. ALL THE REST. LET'S
HEAR FROM YOU, UH, SENATOR
NEWMAN S¼ B 1113. YOU KNOW, THE
WHOLE COMMITTEE IS VERY EXCITED
TO HEAR FROM YOU. MORNING
MEMBERS. LOOKING UNUSUALLY
DAPPER, ALL OF YOU. I THANK YOU.
UM AND THANK YOU, EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR INTEREST IN THIS IMPORTANT
SUBJECT, UH, MR CHAIR AND THOSE
MEMBERS WATCHING SOMEWHERE.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S¼ P 1113
, WHICH WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE ON 10 EXISTING BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PS ACROSS
THE STATE. UH, BEFORE I BEGIN,
I'D LIKE TO MAKE CLEAR THAT I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSULTANT. BRYNN
COOK, UH, FOR HER GOOD WORK ON
THIS BILL, AS I'M SURE THIS
COMMITTEE IS AWARE THE
CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING AND REDUCTION ACT.
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE BOTTOM
BILL AUTHORIZING A FIVE CENT FEE
ON ALL CANS AND BOTTLES AS PART
OF SOME SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION.
UH, WE INTRODUCED, UH, THE
POSSIBILITY TO ESTABLISH FIRST
FIVE AND THEN 10 AS A RESULT OF
A OF ANOTHER BILL, UH, PILOT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
EXPLORE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES,
UH, TO MAKING, MAKING IT EASIER
AND MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR
CONSUMERS TO RECYCLE THEIR CANS
AND REDEEM THEIR èC VÆ èC R
VÆ. THAT BILL HAD A SUNSET, UH,
WHICH IS COMING UP RELATIVELY
QUICKLY. UH, AND, UH, ALTHOUGH
THE RESULTS ARE INCONCLUSIVE. I
AM ASKING TODAY FOR AN EXTENSION
OF THAT SUNSET TO ALLOW FOR AN
ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF MARKET
CERTAINTY TO ALLOW THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS
TO CONTINUE PURSUING THE MODELS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN EXPLORING.
UH AND SO, WITH THAT, UH, I HAVE
A WITNESS, UH, FROM THE
SACRAMENTO PROGRAM. UH, MR TONY
GONZALEZ, UH, TO SPEAK TO THE
BILL TODAY, AND I'M SURE ALL
EAGER TO HEAR FROM HIM. UH AND
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN. AND THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR MEMBERS. UH, I'M TONY
GONZALEZ. I REPRESENT TOMRA
SYSTEMS, A GLOBAL RECYCLING
COMPANY WITH OPERATIONS AROUND
THE WORLD IN EVERY JURISDICTION.
UH, THAT HAS A DEPOSIT PROGRAM,
UM, INCLUDING SOON TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA. UH COMING BACK TO
CALIFORNIA. I SHOULD SAY, UH,
OUR PILOT PROJECT IS IN
PERMITTING REVIEW RIGHT NOW IN
THE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY. UM IF
YOU KNOW WHERE THE RAIS IS IN,
UH, THE FAIR OAKS AREA. IT'S A
STATE OF THE ART FACILITY THAT
WOULD BE STATE OF THE ART IN
TERMS OF CALIFORNIA. UH,
RECYCLING CENTERS BUT PRETTY
STANDARD AS FAR AS WHAT YOU
WOULD SEE IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
IN NORTH AMERICA, WESTERN EUROPE
AND IN, UM NEW SOUTH WALES,
AUSTRALIA. UM WE'RE HERE TO, UH
UH, GIVE A PARTICULAR SHOUT OUT
TO CALVER CYCLE, AND DIRECTOR
WAGNER FORMER DIRECTOR WAGNER IN
PARTICULAR FOR THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE PILOT PROJECTS TO SEE WHAT
WORKS. WHAT DOESN'T WORK. TAKE
LESSONS LEARNED SO THAT WE CAN
INFORM HOW THE HOW SB 10 AND 13
CAN BE FULLY REALIZED. UM AND
WE'RE GOING THROUGH RULE MAKING
ON THAT RIGHT NOW, AND THAT'S
PROBABLY ALL YOU WANT TO HEAR
FROM ME TODAY ABOUT, UH, I DO
HAVE PHOTOS OF WHAT THIS PROJECT
WILL LOOK LIKE, IF ANYONE'S
INTERESTED, BUT, UH, WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
THANK SENATOR NEWMAN FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL. OK LET'S
UM YEAH, LET'S HEAR FROM YOU.
ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AWESOME. THANK YOU. OK,
ANY OPPOSITION CONCERNS. I WILL,
UM, ASK FOR A MOTION WHEN
YOU'RE, UM WHEN MY COLLEAGUES
RETURN. I APPRECIATE THAT AND BY
WAY OF A CLOSE. UH, IT IS A VERY
NARROW BILL. ALL THE BILL DOES
IS GRANT ADDITIONAL TIME, UH, TO
THOSE PILOT PROGRAMS SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE THEIR WORK. IN
SOME CASES, AT LEAST ONE OF THEM
IS IN IN, YOU KNOW, IN PURSUIT
OF ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
EXTENDING THE PILOT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO DO THAT, YOU KNOW, WITH
PRIVATE INVESTMENT BECAUSE THE
STATE FUNDS HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED
AND USING SACRAMENTO AS AN
EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW, IT'S TAKEN
THIS LONG TO GET THE PROGRAM
STARTED. SO WE WANT TO GIVE THEM
TIME. UH TO GET UP, GET RUNNING
AND DO THE WORK OF FIGURING OUT
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE BEST WAYS
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO RECYCLE
THEIR BOTTLES AND CANS? SO WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN
I WELL, I ACTUALLY THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE IS A CO-AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL. SO MAYBE SHE SHE'S GONNA
MOVE IT. OK GREAT. WONDERFUL
GREAT. UM, LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
SB 1113. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS, ALLEN ALAN, I DALLY.
GONZALEZ. HURTADO. MENJIVAR.
WHEN I SKINNER THANK YOU. WE'LL
PLACE IT. STILL ON CALL. THANK
YOU. THREE. CAN WE, YOU KNOW, IN
EDUCATION? IT'S A FULL ROOM, SO
I THINK THAT SHOWS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE, UH THE MORE INTERESTING
OF THE TWO COMMITTEES. THANK
YOU. MORE UM, AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE GONNA HEAR UM S¼ B. ITEM
FIVE. S¼ B 11 THREE SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, ADAM. CHAIR UM
UH, THIS IS, UH, I I'M
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN. WHO? I. I, UM CAN
AT TEST IS HAS GOT A VERY RASPY
VOICE. I THINK HE'S GETTING SOME
SLEEP, SO HE'S NOT FEELING WELL.
BUT BUT THIS BILL, UM UH,
REVISITS THE LEGISLATORS, UH,
DIRECTION WHEN WE CREATED THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES, WHICH
HE CHAIRS BACK IN 2016 UPON, UH,
THE REAUTHORIZATION OF THE CAP
AND TRADE MARKET BASED MECHANISM
PROGRAM, AND THE INTENT WAS TO
HAVE THE COMMITTEE PROVIDE
ONGOING AND PERMANENT OVERSIGHT
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STATE'S CLIMATE POLICIES. UH,
THE BILLS? UH, THIS BILL UPDATES
THE INFORMATION THAT THE CAR
PROVIDES TO THE COMMITTEE
SPECIFICALLY, INCLUDING UPDATES
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS AS THE
STATE MOVES TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY. UH, LAST MONTH, THIS
COMMITTEE, ALONG WITH BUDGET SUB
TWO HELD A HEARING ON CARBS CAP
AND TRADE RULEMAKING, FOLLOWED
BY A JOINT CLIMATE COMMITTEE
HEARING LAST WEEK. UH WHICH I? I
WAS THERE. SOME OF YOU WERE
THERE. UH, THESE HEARINGS
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR MORE
DATA AND TARGETED UPDATES FROM
OUR AIRPORT. IN THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE JOINT CLIMATE COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS KEY TOPICS THAT WILL
ENABLE OR HINDER THE SUCCESS OF
CARBON NEUTRALITY POLICIES,
INCLUDING FOCUSING ON
IMPLEMENTING THE SCOPING PLAN,
GREENHOUSE GAS TRENDS, POTENTIAL
GAPS IN DATA COLLECTION AND DATA
COMMUNICATION. I KNOW THE AUTHOR
IS VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AS THE BILL ADVANCES
AND I CERTAINLY ASKED THE
COMMITTEE FOR AND I VOTE. AT
THIS TIME IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO SAY
YOU SUPPORT IT. ANY ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE SEE NONE. UM I'M THE ONLY
ONE HERE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MR CHAIR? I APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION, AND I GUESS WE
CAN. UM WE REALLY NEED MEMBERS
TO COME BACK. SO I. I REALLY
LIKE, UH, OUR FOLKS THAT COME
BACK BECAUSE THERE'S OUR THIS IS
OUR LAST BILL, AND WE AND, UM
UH, BUT I, I WILL SAY I'VE
REALLY ENJOYED BEING ON THIS
JOINT. THE JOINT CLIMATE
COMMITTEE AND, UH, THEY THEY,
THEY, THEY REALLY PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE. OBVIOUSLY WE
LOOK AT CLIMATE ISSUES AND EQ,
BUT, UM THEY'VE BEEN AN
IMPORTANT FORUM FOR MEMBERS FROM
BOTH HOUSES TO GET TOGETHER AND,
UH, DISCUSS OUR PATH MOVING
FORWARD, AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
DO TO HELP TO FURTHER EMPOWER
THAT COMMITTEE, AND WITH THAT, I
HOPE THAT MY COLLEAGUES WILL
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO TO BECOME CHAIR AGAIN,
AND MOVE. YOU GUYS, ARE YOU GUYS
NOT I CAN IF I CAN.
UH, I. I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FROM MY COLLEAGUE. OK, SO WE'LL
MOVE. SO UM, SENATOR MOVED. S¼
LM 36. WE CAN CALL THE ROLL. S¼
B 136. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS ALLEN
AYE, ALAN. I DOLLY GONZALES.
HURTADO. MENJIVAR. WHEN I
SKINNER. OK ALL RIGHT. THAT'S ON
CALL. SO WHY DON'T WE LIFT CALLS
SO THAT SENATOR NGUYEN CAN GET
ON HER? MERRY WAY? OH, CONSENT
CALENDAR. LET'S MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. UM YEP. OK, LET'S CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OK? YEAH, AS LONG AS
CONSENT IS SB 1046 THE MOTION
CONSENT AND S¼ B 1087. OK LET'S
DO THAT. OK SENATORS ALLEN
ALLEN, I DOLLY! GONZALEZ.
HURTADO. MENJIVAR WIN WHEN I
SKINNER. OK, THANK YOU. JO. OH
DID SHE NOT WANT TO VOTE FOR
THAT A OK, OK. UM OK, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO. I'M GONNA GO
HEAD OVER TO.
SO TAKE A BRIEF RECESS.
YEAH OK, WE'RE GONNA RECONVENE
THE HEARING TO LET OUR COLLEAGUE
ADD ON. SO LET'S UM GO THROUGH
THE ROLE. LET'S START WITH ITEM.
UH, WE'LL START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OOPS. SORRY ABOUT
THAT, ALAN. I? YEAH. DALLY.
GONZALEZ. HURTADO HURTADO. I
MENJIVAR. SKINNER. OK, LET'S NOW
DO ITEM FOUR. THAT'S NEWMAN'S S¼
B 1113. GONZALEZ. HER TATO HER,
TATO, I MANJAR SKINNER. OK?
LET'S GO TO ITEM FIVE. S¼ B 1136
THAT'S SENATOR STERN'S BILL.
JOY. GONZALES. HURTADO HURTADO.
I MENJIVAR. SKINNER. GREAT AND
THAT'S FINALLY UM WE'LL WRAP UP
WITH SENATOR OH, WOULD YOU WOULD
YOU MIND MOVING? 158 THIS IS
ARCHULETA BILL. OK SO MOVED BY
SENATOR HURTADO. LET'S UH LET'S
UM UH, OPEN THE ROLE ON THAT. UH
DALLY GONZALEZ. OH, HE HASN'T.
OH, I APOLOGIZE. SENATORS,
ALLEN. DALI GONZALES. HURTADO
HURT TATO. I MENJIVAR WHEN
SKINNER OK, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR, SO WE'LL NOW DO ANOTHER
BRIEF RECESS. UM AND WILL BE IN
TOUCH. THANK YOU.
UH, IT'S FUNNY, SO WE'RE GONNA
REACH THE EDUCATION, UM IS, UH,
CANNIBALIZING BECAUSE I HAVE TO
GO OVER THERE, TOO, AND PRESENT
SO WE WILL RECONVENE AND WE, UM
WE'LL WE'LL LET OUR OUR FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE AND SKINNER ADD
ON. SO LET'S START WITH THE
ROLE. UM ITEM ONE. SORRY. YEAH,
ITEM ONE. YEAH, THE VOTES ITEM 1
1036 TO 2036 FILE ITEM ONE S¼ B
1036. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TO ZERO AND THE CHAIR VOTING
YES. DALLY. GONZALES. MENJIVAR
SKINNER SKINNER. I OK, LET'S GO
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. A ITEM
TWO S¼ B 1046 FILE ITEM THREE SB
1087. SENATORS GONZALEZ MENJIVAR
SKINNER SKINNER THE VOTE THAT
WAS 3 TO 0. OK, BUT BEFORE THEN
ON THE CONSENT. YEAH, IT'S 40
NOW WITH YOU. YOU'RE GOOD. IT'S
CONSENT, OK? OK WELL, NEXT GO
TO, UH, SENATOR NEWMAN'S 1113 S¼
B 1113 94 OK? FILE ITEM FOUR. SB
1013. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I DOLLY
GONZALES. MENJIVAR SKINNER
SKINNER. I ALL RIGHT, AND THEN
THAT'S FOUR TO ZERO. OK NOW
WE'LL GO TO SENATOR STERN'S
BILL. UH, 1136. OK S¼ 1136. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I DALLY GONZALEZ MENJIVAR
SKINNER. HØI SKIN OR EYE. OK,
THEN. FINALLY ITEMS. THAT'S 4 TO
0. UM ITEM 6 1158 ARCHULETA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION DHI. GONZALES
MENJIVAR WHEN SKINNER SKINNER I
OK THANK YOU, SENATOR FOR COMING
DOWN. I APPRECIATE IT. UM WE
WILL. WE WILL NOW. YEAH, TOTALLY
. YEAH. SENATOR DOLLY WASN'T
HERE. SO WE, UH WE WENT WENT
PARTICULARLY QUICKLY, OK? I
FIGURED THERE WOULD BE AT LEAST
TWO. YEAH, YEAH. NÓ AND I THINK
EDU EDUCATION. UM UH,
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I APPRECIATE
YOU. UM, LET'S LIFT THE CALL.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM ONE. A S¼
P S¼ P 1036. S¼ VÆ 1036. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 30 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I DOLLY. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ, I MENJIVAR OK, OK,
WE'LL DO THE CONSENT COUNTER.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS FILE
ITEM TWO S¼ B 1046 FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE S¼ B 187 DOLI
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I MENJIVAR.
IT. OK HOW ABOUT, UM S¼ P 1113.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I DOLLY
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ, I MENJIVAR.
OK THAT'S 5 TO 0. UM HOW ABOUT
S¼ B 1136 STERN. MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I DALLY
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ, I AND
MENJIVAR OK AND THEN 5 TO 0. UH,
FINALLY, WE'VE GOT S¼ B 1158
ARCHULETA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I DALLY
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I MENJIVAR.
THERE YOU GO. EXCELLENT THANK
YOU, LENA. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
WE'LL WIN. SO MENJIVAR I OK? SO
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE ROLL ON S¼
P 1158 ITEM SIX AND WE'LL GO
BACK THROUGH THE ROLE FOR
SENATOR MENS BAR, SO WE'LL START
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, LENA. I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL, UH, ITEM ONE
S¼ B 1036 LIMÓN. OK THE OFFSETS
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING.
I DALLY MJ. MJ. I OK, UH, THAT
WILL CLOSE THE RULE ON THAT.
THAT'S A 5 TO 0 VOTE NEXT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM TWO. SB 1046
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE S¼ VÆ
1087 CHAIR VOTING I DALLY. ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL CLOSE THE RULE.
THAT'S A 6 TO 0 VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. UM, ITEM FOUR
S¼ B 1113 BY NEWMAN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED, AND RERE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I DOLLY MENDAR. MEN OF
OUR EYE. WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL ON
THAT 6 TO 0. UH ITEM FIVE. S¼ B
1136 STERN MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR. VOTING. I
DALLY. AND M MI-6 0. ALL RIGHT,
THAT CONCLUDES OUR VOTES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, FOLKS. UH, THIS
IS THE BY FAR THE EASIEST
HEARING WE'RE GONNA HAVE THIS
YEAR. I FEAR, UH, BUT GLAD TO
GET, UM, THESE BILLS THROUGH
AND, UM THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
STAFF AND LOOK FORWARD TO A
RIPPER ON APRIL 3RD. YEAH. THANK
YOU.